[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
star wars
happy friday it's star wars time
star wars squadrons is out today my name
is rob we have
a lot of fun times ahead of us um
let me turn down the gameplay audio here
a little bit more
how you y'all doing uh yeah let's get
right into it so things today i'm gonna
be playing
some straight up multiplayer and then
jumping into
gosh some vr um
let's switch over here
enough said right let's get right into
it some dog fighting preferred faction
i don't know let's start off with uh new
republic
so yeah i've been playing a good amount
of this game um
i have a pretty decent setup just kind
of give some uh
some preface here so i have my
thrust master thrustmaster warthog
throttle and a logitech 3d pro
joystick the bummer about it because
i've been um
again this game's awesome it's been
touting a lot of joystick support
um it's funny i bought uh it's over here
somewhere the
the action you know it's a two-parter
right it comes with the throttle and
then it comes with
the joystick that works great i've been
playing flight simulator with it
and the bummer is i bought these pedals
and i've been trying to like
troubleshoot them
and i need some more time with it floor
pedals
and i had to go back to this extreme uh
3d pro and use that
uh because the pedals were just too
sensitive and i need to like adjust
curves and
um like dead zoning uh they're kind of
cheap
i don't know so i kind of toss them away
and just have
the joystick and the throttle here
um yeah i'm gonna be looking at youtube
chat
as much as possible when i'm in vr not
so much
obviously but uh any questions go ahead
and ask
and um yeah let's do it
i'm gonna start off with the a wing here
ready up so yeah what's cool what do i
like or someone asked already uh
empire or rebels more um
i don't know i don't really know
i think i think uh i think both of them
are pretty fun i
you know there's there's definitely
something uh aesthetically
appealing about a tie fighter's uh
laser fire i just like yo that sounds so
sick though
but um it's funny too like i'm sure you
know right like the canopy of a tie
fighter
it's not a deal breaker by any means but
the canopy
is like somewhat restricted right with
your peripherals
compared to an a-wing which is just like
clear canopy so like especially in vr
like you can just see so much more uh
that goes with like an x-wing as well
um vr is pretty cool i'm not gonna lie
um and this is all cross-play too if you
haven't heard already
um so you can play vr with your
your your buddy on um
if you're on like if you're doing like
pc vr and you're playing with your bud
on ps4 it's all doable look at all these
guys
those are triplets oh no
okay i think we're looking good this is
hap i think it's because i have the vive
set up and it like will boot out uh
i think we're all still okay
everyone can see this right
yeah sometimes it'll just like close the
screen
what what hodos am i using i'm using
again uh
just the thrustmaster warthog throttle
and then i'm using um
a logitech um extreme 3d pro i love
that joystick it's got this the z-axis
yaw on it
let's get right into it so the the
coolest thing about this game
is there's so much to think about um
with power management so you can see in
the bottom left there there
was three meters there as well let's get
into it i'll stop talking
let's get a kill in huh
lock
all shields both front and left
so i have all my all my power shifted to
sh
to uh engines right now so i can have a
better turning radius
and i'm more agile
and also that meter you hear the beeping
beep beep that's
right now i'm in the best zone
for turning and couple that with the
engines
on power management and you're uh you're
looking good
let's try to do a drift there i'll talk
about the drift in a second
there we go now i've shifted powered up
across the board just revert back to
normal here
next target let's get in on him
there it is
now all my power all my power was
now it shifted
so i shifted all my power into the
weapons so i can do more damage
but at the cost of shields and speed
sorry i can't look at chat right now i'm
just gonna keep going oh what are you
doing dude
so
all right who's
this next moving slow
you're done
this guy so you can like double tap also
uh a lot of key bindings i've like had
to like spend
honestly hours on so i have everything
at the ready one of them is just like
all right someone's shooting at you
double tap and lock onto them so you can
see
all right i'm gonna boost all right
here's here's gonna be a drift move i'm
gonna try it out
so you hold it like that
and then you get a little fun audio cue
so if i do if i do this all engines and
the turning
i can avoid it but i got hit by
something else
another one someone's on me
i think it's this guy
who wants to go where
there he is joker
this guy
he's like inside the space station
where is he
there's a drift there he
i'm out of is
ah that was a little closer
so
a lot of kill assists huh
joker
let's catch up with him
where are you going bud
there he is ah
god
oh you're so slow
you don't want to slow down that much
you did your job
oh power to fire power missile launch
catching you up
oh where you going
where'd he get how do you get in there
this
this map's pretty cool there's like
interior i think there's like
health pickups and stuff oh wait hold on
so i love this game you can just like
stop
in midair and there are even perks that
like allow you to do cooler moves like
that
um let's take a look at loadouts later
come on feed me
like you can really feel it when you
like shift your power
away from engines
oh i did it all right that's fun
good work pilots
have you tried to ram starfighters yeah
you can do it it ain't it ain't gonna go
well
um
that's kind of weak i can do better dude
so yeah um let me know what you guys
want to see in the chat
um
and i can show you some stuff if you're
curious i mean we could play single
player but i think
there's been enough preview coverage of
that um
let's just get into another match i'm
still warming up
what's my score
yo guys i didn't i didn't even die
yeah so that's that's a big distinction
so um
rebels have this really cool
as as if the power management i've been
talking about isn't
like enough rebel starships have
another set of mechanics which is
shields so like
if you're doing a bombing run for
instance in a y-wing you can
like on a like a um a capital ship or
something you can put all your shields
in front of you at the cost of of not
having anything
uh protecting no shields behind you um
or vice versa if someone's behind you
you can throw everything to the back
only rebels have that um the imperial
ships
don't but they are just overall more
agile
it's it's a complicated balance uh i
i think it works pretty fine did i get
booted from a server
also i just realized i have shadow play
frame rate in the top left to ignore
that
hey cj cj daily thanks appreciate it
uh how do you like the customizations of
your flyable ships
um yeah so this a-wing is
uh what did i do here um you could do a
lot
it's neat like i could take a y-wing
which is obviously a bomber and i could
kind of customize it to be
faster at the cost of like um
let's see
uh what did i do here even well let's
let's try something else out actually
let's do an x-wing for now um
again you can like you can really change
stuff up so like you have
uh your basic fighter your bomber your
interceptor
uh faster hard-hitting and then like a
support ship so this one you could like
fire like mines or like turrets
that can just like shoot stuff or you
can drop health pickups for people
um pretty standard
uh but i could again i can customize
this ship and
and make it something completely
different i can make it in like an
office
offensive type ship that's like faster
uh
more lined with like a fighter um so
it's fun
uh it's interesting the loadouts are
like kind of intense where
there's there's a there's a pretty heavy
consequence
to certain abilities and stuff like
you you have to be cognizant of like
your whole layout i guess
or loadout like if you're if you're
going to put all your
power or have a loadout where it's like
my whole is just going to be
100 on shields i have to kind of account
for that for everything else and make
sure that
everything else in my loadout is
complementary
dude where's the b-wing yo there better
be a b-wing in an update
where this game sucks i'm kidding
use the x-wing okay i will
people need to ready up
[Music]
that's so loud
they they need to turn that down
i want to see customization okay i'll do
that after this
i did i woke up this morning i kind of
thought about it i had i had a beard
going
and you know what i was like screw it
how about how about a nice little stash
like an 80s classic star wars stash i
was
trying to emulate that that one um echo
x-wing pilot from rogue one he had like
the coolest looking stash like so
in line with uh
og star wars look at all these ships
oh yeah i got i got a little blue little
blue uh paint job on that x-wing looks
real hot huh
also i can do vr at any point my fear is
that it might make people sick
but um if you guys really want to see
that uh
we can make a switch i actually haven't
used it in multiplayer quite yet
oh they're already on
everyone strapped into their safety
harnesses
whoa whoa whoa whoa chill chill
chill
all right so right now i have the prime
to enemy lock if they fire a missile i'm
in i'm in the prime situation now i got
my turning speed perfect
whoa this is chaotic
back missile locking they're on me i do
have counter measures so i can use them
if i need to
ah
come on
this looks kind of choppy
there's yeah right behind me
i'm hungry i'm hungry i'll pull off
that's a missile on me it's this guy
it's this xbox man xbox man
man that was chaotic
all right let's watch you die whoa i had
a couple guys on me
oh you know what see this is the thing i
have a weird layout
bot uh the the dial the circular dial
circular dial on the right there
see me swapping to it i don't think i
had any shields behind me
i had accidentally done that
all right let's do this
whoa where are you going
suck that missile
see i like maps like this where there's
tons of obstacles and stuff to like
fake people out on someone's army stop
he's [ __ ] slow down
damn it max multiplayer
level i don't i actually don't know that
that's a good question
[Applause]
that was bad i'll be better
engine's hot i'm on the way
you can change the clip whoa
this ah a lot of people are just like
straight ups stopping and taking the
view and
i love it all right ty interceptor here
enemy locking who are you
who are you
tattooed
ah pain it lead it baby leave those
shots
ah
pick up here give me that full repair
luke
luke you're an imperial now
look at this guy
so i think i have um
this guy looks cool oh man there's
someone behind me i want this though
all right i'm gonna put all my shields
behind me
[Music]
there's just so much to think about like
i should have
uh what was i talking about whatever
all right should i do vr next uh next
round
the problem is i can't see you guys in
chat obviously because
i'm i'm jacked in
oh yeah i know this thing i have i have
a um a loadout where my
my lasers fire all four um at once and
it's like higher damage but like
lower um lower speed
almost someone's behind me
shield's behind me i'm gonna put my
shield
i just want you dead
come on all right
xbox man let's get some fire on that
so can i have all my power now and on
engines
there you are there's my x there's my
man
xbox man
pac-man
this guy's nimble
seems behind me fire it fires
god
all right fine red boy
whoa
repairing
wow
damn luke m8 deflected and became the
best
star fighter in the world galaxy
not the world all right let's get going
what is with people slowing down like
that
ah this isn't good
ignore that no one saw that
my head
let's get some fire on that
damn oh brutal
[Music]
foreign
that was not he's not great on my
pleasure
[Music]
i kind of i kind of let them outdo me
that was not uh great
i don't know trigger happy great
okay should we do vr john luke i think
i'm gonna do it
oh well that's why people really no
never mind
well let's let's look at some loadouts
actually i think people wanted to see
that because
i find it uh very interesting as you
progress so i got some stuff i could buy
right so let's go to customization here
this guy is good hot though uh
so here's my star fighter
uh you can obviously change your pilot
looking so sick uh these
have been kind of rolling out i could i
could pick one of these
eleons uh
you got you know different helmets
you know these are like classic y-wing
helmets
um
body type different suits
different jackets
pants i mean you really only see these
and like
menus right obviously um
emotes and happy to see me
happy to be here i'll outfly
anything it is kind of funny to like put
like a female voice on a male is it's
just a little off
i won't let i won't let us down
anyways that's cosmetics uh
let's check out some stuff here
so this is what i was talking about so
if you go you can have like two
different
kind of presets so i can edit
and here's what we're looking at um
so like i have like a repair function i
could just like remove that if i feel
confident enough
and just like so there's a there's only
two modes right there's dog fighting and
then there's
also um the fleet battles which is
a lot of this stuff kind of is more
pertaining to that
like you can see in the bottom left
there like i deal against capital ships
and stuff like
you don't necessarily need some of the
stuff for dogfights so that's why you
kind of want to like customize different
loadouts
this i'm talking about with whole so
it's like
what's a good example here
whole integrity um it's a better
look here yeah like speed and changing
speeds takes longer
but you're stronger um so it's like
it's cool you get to kind of just like
customize um
you know how you want to play the game
um
this is like uh what's the um what's the
call of duty
uh like drop a grenade when you die
sometimes we'll
beat me to it um that's basically this
so when you when you die you explode
and you can damage other people i can't
remember it in call of duty
and then what else do you got you got
um cool you know what's funny is this
one looks
so overkill it's just like chrome
rusted like it's a bit like it's been a
in a backyard resting in a
junkyard um yeah i icons and these are
kind of funny and silly
you get like this guy
and
little bobble heads and stuff anyways
enough that i think i think we all get
the idea
um all right so i guess
i guess we do vr um
this is gonna be weird
let's try it
i have played no hud and uh it's weird
it's not enjoyable um i mean you can
actually there's there's good
hud customization options so you could
like
um minimize certain stuff
uh i haven't actually gone into it but i
would like to at some point
all right
i'm just gonna straight up reboot the
game
hang tight
this is a vive yes
okay we're looking good on audio
playing with no hut there's like uh
overall settings
you just like it's like a hardcore
setting where it's it's just that like
you can just like
have um no hud whatsoever
fully realistic
thanks sean luke for helping me out by
the way
yeah you like my stash
okay
dude keeps bouncing out to desktop
all right i think you see it
okay i'm gonna i'm going in
i'm going in uh
jean-luc this looks good i don't know i
can't really see your response actually
yeah get your barf bags ready uh i'll do
a match and i'll check
chat why does it keep bouncing out
i just need to put it on all right
i'm doing it
i'm terrified that i'm just gonna like
mess this up and you guys are gonna be
pissed at me for 10 minutes or so it's
also a little difficult
not gonna lie to not see the joystick
and the buttons but
that's that's life
okay it looks good right
no game audio
oh it did it okay okay okay you should
hear it now
my god
now i don't hear it
i'm gonna restart the game
it's tough it's really tough to stream
vr but john luke
and i uh spent a few hours last night
trying to do it
and we got it working and it was working
this morning we'll get there
[Music]
okay
yeah i i have it set to auxiliary
jean-luc i'm pretty sure it's good
all right
hang tight it'll work
oh my god
it'll work
one second
the mustache backstory um
was i went for it
that's it i said screw it let's go let's
let's
let's change things up it's star wars
squadron's day
welcome to a star wars squadron stream
where
a good part of it is me setting up the
vr
apologies
please hang in there
this is gonna work i'm like super
confident it's gonna work
no it'll be fine
jean-luc doesn't need to come over
okay sorry sorry hang tight
okay i can hear it can you guys you guys
should be able to hear it right
no you shouldn't be able to hear it oh
my god i'm sorry guys
one second one second one second
i don't hear audio
that's the bummers i don't hear it um
restart the voice meter and take out the
other headphones okay
hang in there i'm super sorry we'll get
there
okay i hear it now do you guys hear it
slap maybe slack me jean luke i know
you've been doing that
i'm super sorry
yep
just one last confirmation from chat
[Music]
you should hear it
[Music]
yes yes yes yes yes it's quiet all right
i turned up a little bit john luke if
you want to
take over i'm gonna i'm gonna do this
[ __ ]
[Music]
okay god i'm so sorry now stop saying
sorry
fun times okay
let's do another dog fight
vr is pretty cool i'm not gonna lie
so there's something there's only like
one option to like turn here we go sick
there's only like one option either
you're in cross play or not
so like if you are you know
afraid maybe um i don't think it's a
huge deal like i don't think
there's anything necessarily to worry
about if like like the vr helps but it's
not like
i don't know it's not like that
beneficial or like um what's the word
uh there's there's not a whole lot of of
an advantage i think
um so if you're like playing on
ps4 and you don't want to be paired up
with someone on um
pc playing vr you can just turn it off
and just stick to your platform that was
a super long-winded way of saying it
man i wish i could see chat but i can't
let's go
see i'm going to use the a-wing uh
because it's got that
real nice canopy
ready up there's the u-wing gunship
two people let's go come on
make sure it's still working 9 8
nine ten nine out of ten here we go hey
guys
i'll also try to avoid like jerkiness
because i don't want anyone throwing up
not on a friday you know
yavin
look look
no
the game crashed
so
the game crashed
let's try it again
f is right
this one's so much smoother the other
day
it's quite the bummer happy friday
everyone
if you uh
if you're just joining us we're uh we're
playing star wars squadrons vr
it's going really well
all right i'm in yeah i'm just gonna
ready up
come on
please work
oh the issue is my mouse sometimes the
mouse sorry i'm so sorry
okay that's better
oh yeah let's just start let's just get
into it
i'm not gonna do anything at all
please please
please just do it just do it
do it do it
okay that's good
yes
truly
this party
i just flew right into that so we're off
to a real fun start
i got your
i feel better too
i see you
i see you baby
yeah i'll be that
elevated
marrow
someone's behind me counter measures
where you at where you at oh something's
going in here let's go in here
oh what's in here what is this what's in
here
i'm gonna jump on this guy he thinks
he's he thinks he knows what he's doing
but he doesn't
oh he's over there now
who's next
pod
this will launch take it that was me
yeah that was me
all right who's next who's next
what we got what we got honestly it
actually is so much better to like see
someone
like above you oh he's on me
this guy
you're all over me someone's behind me
that's not good it's not good
i'm okay i'm okay i'm okay
i'm okay 69
69 shields
uh counter measures give me him
not good [ __ ] meryl use
son of a gun
it's weird how it goes back to this like
screen
presentation view alright let's go
deploy deploy deploy
i'm ready
done
front power front shields do it yeah so
i shifted all my shields to the front
that was sick
leave him alone
oh maro look who it is
oh
come on come on
come on come on
oh
that's not good
incoming
too yeah it was
whoa
it's taking in the view
suck it
die die
sorry i'm screaming
let's get in here
oh marrow is chasing me i thought so
narrow
oh man this guy's this guy's good
oh
i think he i think he ran into something
oh oh
interior huh
that's me that's me there i am in the
front
what an original pose everyone's
everyone's doing it
all right how did that go
yeah i know some frame drops as well
uh what is it using for controls uh good
question so i have um
i talked about it earlier uh so i have a
thrustmaster warthog throttle and
a um logitech
extreme 3d pro thrust master as well
uh those are my two and i have like all
the key bonding set up so i have like
front and uh basically shield management
here
i have shield management on the joystick
here uh
what else do i have this is like my
loadout i put there
uh boost is on this joystick um
yeah it's fun to like customize all that
you weren't sick at all that was so that
was good
thanks jarrett appreciate it
yeah i'm using a htc vive
i just want to see if chat says that was
okay
yeah so i have um i have the joystick
for the
uh thrust uh sorry excuse me uh the
hodas thrustmaster warthog
but i also have pedals and the pedals
just were not cutting it
they were ultra sensitive i was trying
to adjust like curves and like
using the like firmware apps and
everything and it just was not cutting
it
everything was good okay cool all right
i'm gonna keep going then
uh how about how about uh how about our
next wing here huh
hey everyone it sucks my like
i have some drift so it's kind of
frustrating where are you looking
damn mean mugging right here
i think i have key bindings set for like
emotes and stuff let me see
i thought i did
maybe not oh i hate how it's stripping
like this
sucks
yeah it's my joystick this is uh this is
an older joystick the extreme 3d pro um
so it's like i'm barely trying to center
it
it sucks i could just maybe keep it
consistent with this oh there we go
that's that's worse
so let's see i can um i can mess with
some stuff here how about we do that
as we wait for everyone to get ready
looks like we're about to start though
inspect inspect ooh i can just get
closer huh
that's cool
i'm gonna get in the cockpit can i do
that
like this is super cool whoa
[Music]
it's so loud
maybe i'll try to do uh imperial
after this guess i'm like going just the
rebels i just you know again like the
the x-wing and the um a-wing are just
like the best for vr because again
you get like the open canopy in a way um
this is a cool level lots of obstacles
i think we're looking good we're looking
good right
at
you see my throttle that's pretty neat
here's my joystick
let's party
me too oh lots of guys
all right let's go
see you
[Music]
not good not good at all
oh there he is
i see you there you go
oh we're in a death loop here
i'm gonna try something
i have no health though i was gonna do a
drift but oh he's just playing
he's just stopping
all right drift nope stop stop i screw
that up
all right there's a drift
is that him
all right
skip it skip it
i'm your backup i can do better
this this map is intense there's like so
much
structure and obstacles and nooks and
crannies
all right
let's go for the skype
incoming already oh my god
and people are out for me
all right this guy
dude
did i hit something all right
should be okay i think
yep yep we're hit
all right this dude right here oh
[ __ ] you got one on you
[ __ ] excuse me ah dang it
i'll be better i'm sorry
come on
oh
too
that was a little easy
oh there he is
oh my god smells behind me
round and round
woof
come on
ah
oh no
this is getting a little tricky i'm
gonna try something here
ah
that went all right
how we all doing
uh what should we do let's let's try to
go into an empire ship
right
imperial
let's give this a shot
yeah it you can really tell the
difference between like an x-wing and an
a-wing honestly
like
as far as turning radius goes it's
pretty noticeable
that's not fun to look at is it okay
utah interceptor for sure
uh james cameron you you can uh look
around in your ship
um while flying so if i wasn't using vr
like there's two ways of doing it you
can just do like str like straight up
however you want to keep on it but you
can do straight up like free look or you
can do like
quick look so it's like look up look
right look left
look down if you wanted to see your
joystick um in the cockpit
but yeah that definitely helps in
certain situations
absolutely not this is pc yeah
i'm playing on pc with a vive
i'll take care of it and then for those
of you who are joining yeah i have a
controller set up here
um again this is a thrust master warthog
throttle and then i'm using a xtreme 3d
pro um thrustmaster logitech um
a little combo there
absolutely absolutely
okay let's give her a whirl
pc specs uh 1080
ti uh
i just built a new pc i forget the rest
i'm sorry
i should have i should have written the
down i'll get into this
uh ryzen 9 processor
um yeah
on the same map
whoa okay so i gotta re-kind of set this
here um
i feel a little low
okay so i should do this
what i do is i get i hunch down and then
i just like that
don't know about it closer no backwards
okay
i hope that looks good for you guys
here we go
cockpit looks cool you know
so again no shield management in the uh
imperial ships
just power and speed or engines
hi
so again here's a drift move let me try
it
uh oh i ran out of um
energy for my my boost there
it's kind of trippy playing playing um
in vr with this like
it's not claustrophobic but it really
does feel like i'm encompassed
uh given
[Music]
given the cockpit like i'm just it
really feels like i'm in a bubble it's
cool
why wing no yeah
thai interceptors are so sick
so menacing
all right where's this guy
is he on me
cut him off here
slow wait come on
this guy
i'm gonna try this move again boost
it's not working i think i'm just oh
[ __ ]
hi
i got
foreign got a u-wing here
whoa
so again i evaded that because my
turning speed is
perfect and i'm and i have all my power
in um
agility i'm sorry engines which
gives me the best turning radius and
like a death loop as they calm
and you can evade missiles automatically
like that like i don't have to use
counter measures
counter measures
all right let's go close
leave him alone
is he up around here yeah
oh i know he's way up
where are you
it took
hi
oh you're doing it too air brake
whoa
impressive titanfall
[ __ ] behind me
death loop there you are
all thanks to imperial training
rebel fighters
okay
nice
oh
really
oh he may have sent that missile back
there's a there's a loadout option where
like
you can send
you can send enemy um
missiles locked on you ah
uh you can send enemy missiles back um
backwards like towards uh the one who
fired it
oh that's it
cool
all right uh what do we think um
one more
this is fun i'm having fun
one more i'm actually gonna cancel out
oh can i do it real quick
it's hard to do it right now
let's do one more i want to um i think
it looks cooler in vr
uh when you're in a
x-wing or a-wing so i'm gonna do that
one more time
and then we'll call it
oh my god i just quit the game by
accident that was so stupid
whoops
thank you all for hanging in there it's
been a good time
uh happy friday
let's do just one more
yeah it's on ps uh psvr as well jinx
it is pretty cool nbr
sorry it was hard it's hard to like look
either you're in vr or not so i i wasn't
paying attention to the menu
so that was stupid on my part
it's pretty fun in vr not gonna lie it
feels really good this you know it's
funny uh one of our
fellow video producer aaron sampson was
saying like this game was
definitely made for vr in the sense of
like you have these hanger experience or
where everything is stationary and
everything
um
you want to see a support chip okay i
can do that
all right
oh no is there no game audio
doesn't look like there is
one second
hang tight
no mass
check check check
okay we should be good
you guys can hear this right
i can show fleet battles maybe i'll just
play a bit of this
um that that gets to show off i think
the support ships and everything
um a bit more
all right so
let's do a u-wing right let's do a
y-wing i like the cockpit of the y-wing
i changed my mind
i actually forgot how long these matches
are so let's just do
one more um
one more dog fight and i'll show off a
support ship
um the fleet fleet battles are pretty
cool it's just like
a tug and pull like um at the
at the end of the day it's just like
destroy the other um
destroy the other uh capital ship really
am i gonna get in trouble for it
i mean that's fine
i'll take a loss
come on
happy friday
skyrim vr that's like that's the stuff
that gets me sick
if i play for like long periods of time
anything anything vr related where it's
like
cockpit stitch like seated i'm i'm good
for
ever i i don't really ever get sick from
it
there's that there's that lovely siren
all right here we go
[Music]
the wiring has like an ion turret on the
top
it's fun to just turn that on and it'll
just shoot at everything you can hear it
that was like the nerdiest thing making
that sound effective
all right
that looks really orange
is this just the map i don't think i've
played this map before oh my god
whoa i haven't seen this map before
freaking like
vanguard one is here that's cool i'm
gonna have to reset
this a little bit
so like standard oh god they're on me
already so what you can do
bear with me oh i need to like re-center
myself
okay let's try this again get me out of
here
here i come okay that
that's better
let's party
oh yeah so i have a um a loadout on this
y-wing where it's like
it like takes if there's a delay in the
it's like a rotary cannon
uh primary weapon where like it takes a
delay to spin up but it's like super
high powered all right
some zombies
oh
he disabled my ship
that's cool
that wasn't so cool though
let's see about
uh
whoa where are you coming from
wrecked
i'm ready for a fight
no i lose controller support
oh
my keyboard and joystick just went dead
oh there we go [ __ ] that was a little
scary
okay
so that that's
not ideal for dog fighting so maybe this
isn't the best loadout but
um that's good for like again capital
ships in that one mode
um
sounds cool as [ __ ]
don't worry
this is a cool map
there we go
i'm under attack
where are you you want to make a break
for it
oh he took it
oh man i see you
oh god oh here we go
that [ __ ] this does not work
when enemies are moving that fast it's
so funny
it's purely for offensive capital ships
who am i doing
oh no he's gonna do it too i want to
beat him to it
you're close
oh
oh yeah get it oh
you're good now
oh i so almost died sick all right that
was
that was cool
a very orange warm map
okay
let's call it that was fun
got the the vr face now it's hot
this room's hot
thank you all so much for joining me and
being patient with that vr setup
we got there um hope you had a good time
uh
yeah uh we have single player
impressions
up on youtube if you want to take a look
at them we will have
our review full review uh ed tran is
in australia is reviewing that um
the decision was to was to you know uh
play it over the weekend and make sure
multiplayer servers are okay
they seem to be okay right now uh
despite i think
maybe the vr uh can
you know throw a curveball in and crash
your game it's uh it's a lot
but um for the most part uh i i think
it's uh
so far looking pretty good it's a it's a
fun game there's
you know a lot um a lot to do when
you're flying i think that's my
favorite part about this game you know
all the power management stuff um
there's a lot to think about
therefore like a lot uh to
to hone in on to develop as far as
skills and timing and
um yeah i i enjoy it uh and hope you
guys enjoyed the stream
but uh yeah stay tuned next week for
that uh early review
the full review from ed and we uh we're
gonna call it
happy friday everyone have a great rest
your day
and we'll see y'all next time
bye